It's been 15 years since the fall
The city is a corpse and we are the worms
We burrow in it
Fighting for every useful piece of land to preserve ourselves
From the terrors of the night and the horrors of the day
Who can hear my voice I shall therefore speak a word up to hear
Anyone who dares to steal food will behind and their body will be exposed
Every day we rise from dust to choose between bad and worse
Get him!
You're dead now!
These choices we take to survive will create the world to come
You literally get to the nearest safe house and wait until dawn good night and good luck
Sunlight two features a functioning ecosystem it reacts on multiple levels to the things you do and the choices you make in the example
We're about to show you our protagonist undertakes a mission for the peacekeepers one of the many factions after to the city
They want you to negotiate with two survivors who are controlling and hoarding a water supply
You're going to insult this with another final offer. Let's say you choose to carry out the peacekeepers orders one way or another
After this will start seeing a significant change of the city
As access to the water supply is allowed the peacekeepers to bring stability and develop the air
There's even running water for the people at street level
And that raises their morale and allows you to replenish your energy on the go but there's a cost to this
The PK's of our rigid approach to law and order
So while the streets may be safer it's only safe for those who side with them if you get on their bad side
Now let's return to that moment of choice
And instead of killing them you choose to team up with this group to supply water and black market
As you will see this creates a very different set of consequences for the city
With water being a precious currency it brings you access to new resources and trade
But this in turn attracts the worst type of people to the area
And this is just a single decision one out of hundred you'll have to make
But it allows you to carve out your own world their own city from the apocalypse
Each player's game experience will be unique
And, by the way, this is just what happens the day
at night, well,  things tend to get a lot darker